hey guys came here kanye west is making
a video game and what could be the
greatest celebrity game crossover ever
but we'll let you get crash grammy
speeches find out yes yeah camp imma let
you finish okay imma let you finish but
50 cent had the best video game
celebrity crossover of all time of all
time you dare can yummy in my GF news
video after conquering the music world
and the fashion world rapper kanye west
is taking on his next big challenge
video games world West was on power 105
point ones The Breakfast Club radio show
recently discussing his next album and
his collaboration with adidas when he
briefly mentioned that he's currently
working on a video game based on one of
his songs right now I'm working on a
video game for only one and the idea is
that it's my mother going through the
gates of heaven and you have to bring
her to the highest gates of heaven by
holding her to the light West said we've
been working on it for like six months
west didn't say which platforms the game
is for or who's developing it with him
if it comes to mobile though he's gonna
have to face some stiff competition from
his wife Kim Kardashian who's successful
Kim Kardashian Hollywood mobile game was
estimated to generate as much as 200
million dollars last year through in-app
purchases so are you excited to play
Kanye's game are you worried it might
interfere with the production of South
Park the fish stick of truth and should
I change my name to kami eh let me know
in the comments down below and for more
flippant video game news come on back to
gamespot
you